imagine a place where wishes come
true where your heart's desire can
become a
reality what if I told you that place is
within
reach all you have to do is give your
wish to
me wish commemorates 100 Years of w
Disney Studios um can you talk about how
this special anniversary sort of
inspired this film and and how wish
continues that Disney Legacy well I
think it all started back in
2018 we were still finishing up Frozen
Jennifer Lee had just become the chief
creative officer at Disney and uh
realized that in 2023 was the 100th year
anniversary and went up to Chris and
said hey what kind of a movie should we
do we still had a year to do in Frozen 2
so I was a zombie at that that time so I
about passed out when she said hey how
about another feature to think about but
I couldn't pass it up I mean to
celebrate the 100 years you know we
Disney means so much to all of us we all
grew up on Disney all the characters all
the stories um I was very very lucky
when I first started I was mentored by
Walt Disney's nine old men and Eric
Larson was my mentor so they really were
handing down the Baton to My Generation
Um so now I get the chance to hand the
Baton to the Next Generation and fawn I
can't believe this but this is your
directorial debut it is fantastic can
you talk about sort of what like why
this film why this was the right time
this film talk about the the important
of a person's wish right there's no
greater power really in the universe
than a person with the wish in their
heart and I can relate to that so much I
grew up on Disney film the the '90s uh
musical Disney era that was all the
feels and it made me want to draw and
want to become an artist and had this
wish to work at Disney Animation someday
and to be here to be working on this
film we put all the hope and joy and the
fun that inspired us all into this movie
now who do I have to thank slbe angry
because I'm going to spend so much money
on Little Star
merchandise um th this this thing is the
cutest thing I've ever seen in my life
we knew star was going to come down to
earth and Asha was going to wish on that
star but star started off as kind of a
character that could morph into
different uh characters different
animals even humans had different voices
and then we just kept whittling it down
to the Simplicity it's just this simple
ball of of Hope and joy and inspiration
and and mischievous the animators are so
incredible and they were able to make
you feel and laugh and all of that
without a voice and really fall in love
with star and I would say personality
wise as well uh a breakthrough is in a
meeting Jen's like have you seen this
baby panda videos and uh and baby pandas
were a huge inspiration for Star because
they're so curious and funny I see that
absolutely that's amazing well thank you
star is adorable Julie I do want to ask
about these amazing songs because uh
from what I understand the process is
different when it comes to writing songs
for animation where do you even start so
when they gave me my assignment they
were like here's one paragraph
that's all we had that's all I had to go
on and uh it was basically about this
young woman who lives in this really
magical town and it's run by this very
Charming King that uh basically protects
all these wishes and grants wishes and
she finds out that not everything in
this kingdom is as it seems and thus
starts her journey this very selfless
courageous Brave a journey to save uh
these wishes for for the people and I
really wanted to stick to the essence of
that as much as possible and still make
it feel um really classic but still make
it feel modern we would come in Ben rice
and I who I did the songs with um would
come in and they would sort of give us
our next assignment and we would just
talk about it all together and I think
as my my job as a collaborator the more
information that I get the better and it
really was such a collaborative process
the way that we would talk about the
characters and go into their feelings
and and sort of the expectations of what
we wanted it to feel like and sound like
they played this wish for me and I just
knew I was like this is something I'm
I'm supposed to do this I was absolutely
terrified because I listened to it I
thought it was the most beautiful song
I'd ever heard but then I also was like
oh I have to sing that and I have to
sing it well and it's a it's actually a
deceptively hard song and that was sort
of indicative of the whole process of
figuring out how to make myself so
malleable that I can shift and change
whether I'm in a recording session with
Chris and fawn um I'm really glad that I
said yes to it and you know Julie and I
bickered every once in a while where I
was like girl this lyric I don't really
understand it or this note like could we
maybe pick a lower one and she was like
no no can do it you got it um and you
did and I did it was for me this whole
thing has been um sort of like a lesson
in and stepping out of my comfort zone
and allowing myself to be led in a
different way this is not like making a
a a you know a liveaction feature film
this is you know using your imagination
your own personal creativity to the nth
degree and then you know trusting
in your creative Partners to take it the
rest of the way did you ever dream about
like being a Disney
princess um I mean I grew up watching
all the all of the films you know and I
would dressed like Belle and I think I
dressed like Snow White for Halloween a
couple of times but I don't think I
consciously really thought of becoming
one of these characters in a way I think
I might have accidentally manifested
it now you're manifesting Tinkerbell
yeah I'm okay so I'm doing this weird
but fun thing where I wanted to
celebrate all of the Disney characters
that I loved growing up so I'm picking
different colors and different makeup
plots and you know being my own versions
of them but like we have Asha hair we
love to see um but yes today's today's
Tinkerbell day yes fantastic I want to
talk about the process of working with
actors and and directing them because I
think some people have this this idea
that like voice acting you can you can
show up in your pajamas and it's some of
the hardest stuff you can do and can you
talk about the process of working with
the actors are they ever in the booth
together had to be separate we even had
to be separate I love being in the booth
with the actors but a lot of times we
had to be behind the glass just because
of safety reasons but um no we uh you
know it's 4our Max you know it really
because it's exhausting Ariana just has
this incredible energy that loved you
know and the animators we record the
sessions video and so we make sure the
animators are watching that so her the
little subtleties and the facial things
and and of course she's an incredible
dancer and the thing about your pajamas
is true because I did not do my hair and
I was absolutely in gym
clothes there's there's moments from
like old Disney films that I feel you
can feel their DNA in this movie how
conscious of you were about about going
out and parsing you know the history we
wanted to make an original original
story with you know original characters
original songs uh but we were all Disney
fans ourselves and so that being able to
understand what's at the heart of a
Disney animated movie you know hope Joy
wishing Wishing on stars um I think
that's what what drove us we brought in
people from all over the studio to have
round taes to tell us what Disney meant
for them so we started from a very
emotional point so everything else was
led by that there are over a hundred uh
uh nods to our Legacy and someone you
have the Excel spread yes really you
keeping you ask him later yeah this the
visual style of this film right we were
like let's go back to the beginning and
look at Snow White and Pinocchio and
this gorgeous watercolor story book so
that's inspired this whole style and we
want to blend CG into it to allow us to
walk into the book and and live in it
and be immersed in it we put a huge
challenge on our effects team what if it
looks 2D it's designed it has these
thorns and they got all geeky and nerdy
about it they went to the animation
library and they were like let's look at
the source of the inspiration Ariana did
you ever get to record with Chris Pine
because he's he's a lot of fun too he is
a lot of fun but I will be I'll be
honest we we never recorded at the same
time um in fact I think I typically
would record first and then he would
come in um which is like kind of sad to
me because isn't he just
delicious like he's such a wonderful
villain I think his vocal tone and
quality is just so
buttery and like it he's a wonderful
villain yeah like you love to hate him
but you really love to love him too and
nods to the animators cuz he's a fin
looking
gentleman I want to go into the music a
little more and I I really want to focus
on I wish because you know it was a song
that hooked Ariana and is such an
amazing song where did the inspiration
sort of come from or was that the first
one you started with yeah it was the
first song that I wrote for the film I
actually got a call from Tom McDougall
when the pandemic was happening and he
was like we're working on a new film
it's the 100th anniversary of Disney's
animation film and he's like you know we
have our ly Wells and our
lopezes but we kind of want to try
something new would you be up to trying
and I was like oh my God yes and then I
was like oh my God like you have the
great like how am I supposed to live up
to the expectation of Disney and
Disney's Legacy that's like the biggest
shoes to fill I grew up with these songs
and they shaped so much of who I am
today and you know the more I thought
about the legacy of Disney and how it
really is about believing and wishing
and believing in yourself that you can
do something and so it took a lot of
that in to do this and and make this
film and try and make this film as
special as possible hope that everybody
falls in love with these songs I can
pretty much guarantee it I don't think
you have to worry about that well again
it's such a beautiful movie thank you so
much for all your hard work on it
because it shows in every frame and the
whole world is going to get to see it
pretty soon um so I would say spread the
word you probably don't need to
but word of mouth is so good tell your
friends thank you all for coming out
seeing in the theater today yeah thank
you for thank you guys so
[Applause]
much